so I've already played for you a clip of
Herschel Walker yesterday not very
convincingly denying a second allegation
of him urging a woman to get and
ultimately paying for her abortion you
saw Republican senator Lindsey Graham
just laughing in the background laughing
off the entire thing Lindsey Graham saw
this as a great opportunity
to go on Fox News and to do his I'm
angry routine this is the same routine
he did during the Brett Kavanaugh
confirmation hearings where he framed
Brett Kavanaugh as the biggest victim
maybe not only in the history of the
United States but maybe the history of
the world screaming and just acting
completely ridiculous he is now doing
the exact same thing he appeared
alongside Herschel Walker last night on
Fox News and he says the reason this is
all happening is because everybody is
scared to death about what a black
Republican senator might mean to other
black kids and there may be more
Republicans and it's just scary to
Democrats but they're scared to death of
Herschel Walker because if Herschel
Walker becomes a republican maybe every
other young child in America of color
might want to be a republican that's
what they're trying to do don't let them
get away with it teamherschel.com I want
the biggest night for the Herschel
Walker campaign to be tonight right this
is a character that Lindsay has
developed I call it the faux indignation
where he is just absolutely furious at
grave injustices that don't actually
exist and that are only meant to prop up
bad candidates and the lies of others
and that is exactly what is happening
here Lindsey Graham is uh using this
to try to
justify that Democrats are the real
racists Democrats they only want black
people in power if they are on their
side when of course we actually know
it's the Republican party that has this
very long history of only allowing very
narrowly defined black folks to be part
of their movement uh Herschel Walker
fits the bill take a look at more of
this Lindsey Graham Insanity on Fox News
I Herschel they're beating all of our
guys up but who is what is it about this
guy he changes the entire Narrative of
the lift we're a party of racist Sean
man you're a racist the Republican
party's racist well what happens when
the Republican Party elects and
nominates Herschel Walker an
African-American black Heisman Trophy
winner right Olympian it destroys the
whole narrative John James Tim Scott
Herschel Walker everybody in San
Francisco is going to jump off bridge
now the reality is Herschel Walker
winning first of all Herschel Walker
being nominated changes nothing about
The Narrative of the left and Herschel
Walker winning would change nothing
about The Narrative of a left
Republicans have for a long time
accepted and allowed very specific
minorities useful to them in very
particular ways to try to prove how not
racist they are and in fact they've done
it with Herschel Walker where Herschel
Walker has a platform that is simply
lies he doesn't know what he's talking
about on any political issue the big
issue for him was abortion where it was
absolutely pro-life abortion is murder
no exceptions no exceptions no
exceptions turns out he now has been
accused of urging multiple women and
paying for multiple women to get such
abortions and now when you criticize him
and you go Walker has no clue what he's
talking about he's a liar he's dishonest
and he's a hypocrite they come back and
go that's racist you're that's racist
you're being the racist because you're
saying this guy is a hypocrite and
incompetent no he's racist I'm sorry
he's incompetent and he is unqualified
and that's why we are saying it it has
nothing to do with his race
um he hasn't actually said by the way
even a single thing he would do for
black folks in Georgia nothing he's not
actually articulated a single policy
idea that he has to help black folks in
Georgia
um and then and at this point it's just
beyond belief
Lindsey Graham tries to interfere in the
Herschel Walker stuff by bringing up
Hunter Biden's laptop now you might be
saying well that's important because
Hunter Biden voters have to decide are
they're going to are they going to vote
for Hunter Biden for the position of
for the position of
um oh right Hunter Biden's not running
for anything don't say anything but as I
said earlier they mess with the wrong
Georgian right now well can I say
something yeah the hunter laptop laptop
it was supposed to be Russian
disinformation right before the election
it was true it got suppressed right
before the election have an anonymous
allegation from a lawyer in LA to try to
affect the outcome in a Georgia race
they tried to destroy a Kavanaugh
because they wanted the Supreme Court
see they're afraid of this man coming
into the Senate because he would
transform the Republican Party we're not
going to let him get away with it I'm
tired of it I'm tired of seeing people I
know yeah okay he's Furious We Get It
Lindsay uh by the way the only
transformation that Herschel Walker
would do of the Republican party is he
would continue to prove that there is no
low there there is no standard too low
below which Republican voters aren't
willing to go as long as it isn't a
Democrat you could be out there paying
for abortions and unable to explain your
position on any issue but as long as
you're not Raphael Warnock with a d next
to your name there is no standard below
which these Republican voters won't go
absolutely stunning stuff make sure
you're following us on Facebook
facebook.com
davidpackman show we'll have all of
these clips there for your viewing
horror I guess I would say
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
holdon bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below